Andy how you doing I'm doing very well
yeah mm-hmm you know we we're pretty
lucky here aren't we yeah we have it
good we have it good because we have
this show which has a great time slot
don't you think 12:30 is a great amazing
time you know what's sad I was being
sincere and people had people laughed no
this is a something I want to talk about
in just about every part of this country
this show Late Night with Conan O'Brien
comes on right after The Tonight Show
with Jay Leno which is terrific because
he's doing well and it's right from his
show into our show and a lot of people
see us it's the night shift it's the
night shift maybe it's sort of like
must-see TV but less so yeah less kind
of right yeah maybe you should check it
out time TV yeah
but no pressure right yeah well no it's
true it's it's a it's a cool thing you
know we're on after Jay everywhere
except ladies and gentlemen in one city
Houston I'm not kidding about this
you're from Houston all right we're
gonna have security beat them
they're into that all right okay
apparently they're familiar with our
security yeah Fabio worked security for
us this is pretty impressive I mean it's
amazing Andy do you have any idea this
is a TV Guide that I got from Houston do
you know what time our show goes on the
air in Houston no I do not
all right here this is a Houston TV
Guide in Houston The Tonight Show with
Jay Leno ends then it's followed by
Ricki Lake Access Hollywood these are
all reruns a rerun of the 10 o'clock
news then
hey baby it gets better the Jenny Jones
Show which is another rerun and then
I'm so happy that elicits the real
horror and then finally everybody at
look at this this is sweet you got to
check this out at 2:40 in the morning
Late Night with Conan O'Brien 2:40
that's kind of like don't even bother TV
so now we don't know why Houston is
doing this we don't it's it's their
policy and they've got their own ways
which is cool but I decided that I
should go to Houston drive around late
at night and find out who is watching
the show at that time and what we found
out was I'm kind of interesting take a
look things have really gotten kind of
quiet here in Houston at this time of
night and it is 11:40 which means
there's still three hours to go before
my show I think a lot of people have
gone to bed
or else what I'm hoping is that they're
taking a nap right now they can get up
at 2:40 and watch the show hello you
gonna watch late-night tonight
not tonight he said but he said it the
way a guy would who's watched it most
every night hello how you doing my name
is Conan O'Brien yes you ever heard of
me you can you can come on over you can
say if you never heard of me before
that's fine okay yeah you ever hearing
me before probably not I have a TV show
here at 2:40 in the morning okay you
ever think maybe maybe you saw it once
maybe some night you were sick maybe you
had some a bad cookie or something you
woke up in the middle of the night and
and you had to turn the TV on and I was
there do you think you're gonna maybe
watch it tonight or is that too late you
get to 40 actually if you turn in at
2:30 it's not on yet well if anyone's
gonna be watching my show I figured it's
gonna be these guys let's check it out
I'm just curious
you guys gonna watch any TV tonight yeah
I'll wait you guys out in the morning
you're up til 8:00 in the morning what
do you like to watch what kind of shows
comedy you like comedy
sweet alright well do you watch ever
watch my show Late Night with Conan
O'Brien mmm yeah okay I'm translating
that as a No have you ever seen it no
okay
I tell you what the show is like and you
tell me if you would like it first of
all I'm the host whoo good for you and I
have a guy that sits next to me do you
know him oh well I can't remember his
name Paul Paul
yes it's Paul what's your favorite
television show to watch mesh all the
reruns do well you got it pretty much
restricted to the reruns now it's been
off the air since 1984 did you know that
yes I did I guess you'd have to say my
favorite is uh okay
you like Hawkeye we have a character on
our show named Hawkeye and he he's a lot
like the Hawkeye and mash so maybe you'd
like our show well that sounds
interesting and a good possibility show
he's primarily a medical drama did you
know that so and it's set in Korea in
the 50s would you want to see the show
yes I would like to see it
I think it's a show that Houston would
really like if they got a chance to see
it more often first of all we have lots
of we have a Houston Astro on every week
we've a Houston oiler on every week and
the show starts off with a country music
theme song you want to hear that
I wouldn't mind here let it all
[Music]
[Applause]
I said bye
[Music]
is a robot that comes on the show who's
half him and half robot have you seen
him
yeah I saw him Tim 5m5 save pimp pot
into the Mike b5 thank you
[Applause]
what are places where people gather and
can be found at 2:40 in the morning
[Music]
[Applause]
this is the main emergency room in
Houston I figure they're up all night
I'd see if they're watching hi how are
you are you okay yes I'm fine is your
cold cool do you mind if I turn this
channel okay because see that guy there
see what he's looking miliar he does but
I don't know his name that's me that's
me yeah and look there's the band that's
the band his name is Max Weinberg he was
used to play with Bruce Springsteen and
then something happened I think max was
caught embezzling I don't know they
kicked him out let's take a look just
for a second who I'm up against and
that's Tyra Banks that's a good guest to
have and look what I'm up against here
at five minutes of 3:00 in the morning
okay that's that's the Indian version of
politically incorrect heating up Bill
Maher eat your heart out some kind of
cartoon with no sound I don't know
what's happening to her
I think I don't know this is okay this
is well this is this is Spanish so at
least we're moving closer to the Western
Hemisphere now you have a friend who you
think we should wake up and make watch
the show yes we can Conan O'Brien's unit
Ethan Ethan
Nathan it's me Conan O'Brien how you
doing how are ya
oh yeah how you doing good how are you
good to see you you're not watching this
so give a TV ok let's go it's turns TV
on
you should be up you're not going to
that class it's it done who goes to a
nine o'clock class hey how you doing how
are you oh there's a show on that you're
gonna really like yeah I'm trying to
watch my own show
what's that house it'll show that in who
soon no one at 2:40 in the morning yeah
but they don't start they don't show
that kind of crap in Houston no no no
we're the good crap now yeah you're
talking about the first year no no no
he's good now and I'm good now for the
first year and a half
crap huh but then we got our stuff
together and now it's a good show oh
okay what's your name
oh good I'm trying to find my show it's
on right now first because it's not a
show with a little fat dude he's he's
back in New York City he's in drug rehab
yeah he's taking care of himself
that's good okay I'm gonna try and get
the show all right good to meet you
take care I was just almost murdered to
know that you're gonna ask me to leave I
need you to leave so where will I go out
in the street on the next block
[Music]
[Applause]
oh they're doing very well and I'm 636 -
I'm six foot - yeah we're gonna maybe
what we're gonna do fat dude know what
we're gonna do
tune in to this show this is going to be
our there's gonna be our stuntin sweeps
and inai sometime late in May are gonna
find Buffalo and beat the crap out of
them that's not going to happen cuz he
could take both of us so easy yeah all
right we're gonna take a little break
right now and when we come back stick
around Lisa Kudrow's with